julianne smith u.s ambassador to nato
thank you so much uh for spending a few
minutes talking to us today let's kick
off uh with the expansion of nato what's
the reason to expand nato to include
finland and sweden well the nato allies
over the last couple of months have made
it crystal clear particularly to folks
in moscow that its open door policy
remains the same and for that reason
we welcomed the application by finland
and sweden today when they walked in
with their letters stating their intent
to join the alliance these two nations
share our values and they share a
collective commitment to our security
across the euro-atlantic area they bring
very capable militaries they've
exercised with us for many many years in
places like the baltic sea and we're
confident that when they come into the
alliance and become full-fledged members
in the weeks ahead months ahead that
they will make a major contribution to
the nato alliance
ambassador it can take up to a year for
countries to be allowed into the
alliance for that application to be
processed are you saying you want to
fast-track that into weeks or months
yeah so in recent weeks the allies have
come together to try and look at ways
that they can reduce the timelines
surrounding the process there are a
number of steps involved there's
something called the accession protocol
which all allies have to sign here at
nato and the two new members would sign
that as well in order to get to that
signature we'll have to go through
something called the accession talks
once the protocol is actually signed
then every member of the alliance has to
ratify the agreement which can take some
time and you're right in the past we've
seen instances where that process has
taken upwards of a year but given the
situation on the ground in ukraine the
fact that we have a war that's ongoing
on european territory i think all allies
are in agreement that this process needs
to be expedited so ambassador just be
clear you're hoping to get this achieved
in the coming months so what by the
summer by the end of the year
ideally i think we'd like to see it done
in a couple of months that's the goal
right okay i'm just i'll just bring you
straight to something else then
just in terms of that
once those countries apply it is a
moment of vulnerability and risk
the uk foreign secretary today has
congratulated both countries on the
decision and says the uk will work to
integrate them quickly but what will the
u.s do to protect both countries should
russia
attack them before they are in the
alliance what's your plan
well fortunately for finland and sweden
all of the members of the alliance
recognize that in this process between
the moment when the countries actually
sign the assession protocol the
agreement to join the nato alliance
and the period of ratification all the
way to the point when they become
full-fledged members that there is some
risk involved in this process and for
that reason
aspirant countries going through this
process can sometimes feel a bit exposed
and for that reason
all of the allies many of them have been
in conversations directly with sweden
and finland to find ways that they can
take steps to reassure those two
countries and to send a very strong
clear signal back to moscow that all of
us will
address any future forms of aggression
that any country could take towards
sweden and finland during this period so
as you perhaps have seen the white house
has recently announced that both heads
of state from sweden and finland will be
visiting washington on thursday i think
you'll see more in terms of what the u.s
wants to say about this period but
already as you noted the united kingdom
has been quite clear in its commitment
to the security of those two nations as
well ambassador it sounds like there
could be more news on this specifically
from the white house later in the week
but as you said the uk have signed a
bilateral pact
with both countries to protect them
i'm assuming that you're suggesting that
the us is minded to do the same
we're certainly well aware of the risks
involved and we will take steps to make
sure that they feel that their security
needs are being addressed okay
ambassador just to quickly go back to
that accession process obviously the
white house is clearly minded to approve
uh this application anyone can ask to
join but of course the members of nato
have to agree it turkey is a stumbling
block isn't it it's said it is opposed
the white house said this week it's
confident consensus can be reached can
you explain to us what's going on and
why the white house is confident of that
has president biden been in bilateral
talks
well first and foremost let me say yes
there has been an ally turkey that has
come forward to express some concerns
they have specific security concerns
that they've raised with all of the
allies here at nato headquarters and
we're all taking those concerns very
seriously i think the reason you see the
confidence stemming out of the white
house and in fact many other capitals
across europe and here at nato
headquarters is simply because the
strength of the alliance really rests on
our ability to continually bring forward
disagreements debates alternative points
of view and work through those
disagreements to reach consensus
everything that nato does
has to be reached through consensus you
have to have 30 allies vote on it so we
have 73 years of experience of working
through allied differences and for that
reason i too personally am quite
confident that we'll find a way through
this just be clear then you don't think
in the end turkey will be the block
i think we will see eventually sweden
and finland joining the alliance in the
not too distant future ambassador i've
got a few minutes left just a couple
more things uh let's just get back to
russia nato defensive alliance being a
member is designed to be a deterrent
to attacks from aggressors such as
russia but speaking to russian officials
last week they couldn't be clearer
they're clear that joining nato will
make those countries less safe let's
just have a quick listen to what the
russian ambassador to the european union
told me last week as
my government
has
pointed out
this will necessitate certain military
technical measures
like uh im improving
or raising the now the degree
of uh uh defense preparations along the
finnish border and the russian finnish
border is more than 1300 kilometers i
should remind you
ambassador that you not so russia
warning that it will make these
countries less safe they're warning
about technical measures along the
border are you not worried about further
poking the bear that this actually risks
escalation of the uk and conflict well
look russia has already escalated and
fundamentally shifted the security
landscape across the european continent
russia has started a land war in europe
in 2022 the first of its kind since
world war ii so russia is the aggressor
here i think russia's actions have
triggered some new and fresh thinking in
these two countries and triggered their
decision to join the alliance so the
only concern that i think anyone should
have is about russian aggression i know
for a fact that bringing these two
nations into the alliance will make us
all collectively stronger and certainly
it will make finland and sweden stronger
as well no doubt about that just quickly
when russia says this that it will make
these countries less safe are they lying
or are they bluffing or do you not know
well what they're doing in ukraine is
making all of us less safe collectively
and so we want their actions in ukraine
to stop how they respond to this
potential round of nato enlargement is
up to them but i think right now the
message coming across from the nato
alliance is crystal clear and that is
that russia doesn't get a veto over nato
enlargement policy this decision rests
between the nato alliance and finland
and sweden they have taken the decision
to submit that letter of application and
so we will proceed irrespective of any
threats that russia is going to make but
are you worried about the nuclear threat
ambassador russia's lost a third of its
invading force in ukraine surely the
threat that they are uh
warning of is nuclear surely nato must
be concerned about that and has nato
discussed how it might respond to a
russian nuclear attack surely you are
now gaming this as an option
we are worried any time the russians are
talking talking about using nuclear
weapons whether it's tactical nukes or
some other form of nuclear weapons we
find this rhetoric to be extremely
dangerous and troubling and for that
reason yes we do hear at the alliance
look at all potential contingencies any
potential scenario we do not want them
to turn to rely on these types of
weapons nor do we want to see them use
chemical weapons and that's why i think
you've seen some very clear messaging
both from the white house and from nato
allies about the danger and are urging
them to not turn to these types of
weapons so we take it very seriously and
i think we've all messaged back that
that would incur severe consequences
final question ambassador i'm out of
time i don't expect you of course to set
out nato plans explicitly on how you
might respond
but i think what you're saying to me
that is that the alliance has drawn up
or is in the process of drawing up
response options should russia escalate
this in a nuclear fashion
i think what i'm saying is that the nato
alliance has been planning for this war
in ukraine for quite some time before
russia went into ukraine on february
24th we were conducting
all sorts of planning to prepare for
this possible scenario while we were
working on a diplomatic solution as well
now that the war is under away we're
constantly reassessing how individually
we can support ukraine nato is not
active in ukraine or formally providing
any sort of support but of course as an
alliance we're looking at our individual
contributions to strengthen the
ukrainian forces and preparing for every
contingency and we will keep doing so
okay ambassador thank you very much for
your time